Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
It's been quite a while since we've talked
about a paper on fluid simulations.
Since my withdrawal symptoms are already kicking
in, today, I simply have to talk to you about
this amazing paint simulator program that
runs in real time and on our mobile devices.
These handheld devices typically have a lower
image resolution compared to desktop computers,
therefore it is indeed a challenge to put
together a solution that artists can use to
create detailed paintings with.
And to accomplish this, this piece of work
offers several killer features: for instance,
the paint pigment concentration can be adjusted.
The direction of the brush strokes is also
controllable.
And third, this technique is powered by a
viscoelastic shallow water simulator that
also supports simulating multiple layers of
paint.
This is particularly challenging as the inner
paint layers may have already dried when adding
a new wet layer on top of them.
This all has to be simulated in a way that
is physically plausible.
But we're not done yet!
With many different kinds of paint types that
we're using, the overall outlook of our paintings
are dramatically different depending on the
lighting conditions around them.
To take this effect into consideration, this
technique also has an intuitive feature where
the effect of virtual light sources is also
simulated, and the output is changed interactively
as we tilt the tablet around.
And get this, gravity is also simulated, and
the paint trickles down depending on the orientation
of our tablet according to the laws of physics.
Really cool!
The paper also shows visual comparisons against
similar algorithms.
And clearly, artists who work with these substances
all day know exactly how they should behave
in reality, so the ultimate challenge is always
to give it to them and ask them whether they
have enjoyed the workflow and found the simulation
faithful to reality.
Let the artists be the judge!
The user study presented in the paper revealed
that the artists loved the user experience
and they expressed that it's second to none
for testing ideas.
I am sure that with a few improvements, this
could be the ultimate tool for artists to
unleash their creative potential while sitting
outside and getting inspired by nature.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!